[Música]
i
bueno mi nombre es habían el chico y
tengo 29 años
desde que tienen uso de razón yo siempre
quise ser actriz
una gran actriz
entonces yo siempre debería actuar y
asimilaban que la actuación era sinónimo
de felicidad siempre la veía feliz y mi
sueño era ser actriz para hacer feliz a
los seis años actúe en la noticia de
baby con denisse dibós estaba cumpliendo
mi sueño luego a los nueve años
seleccionada para celular
y
mira
bueno y después cuando estaba en la
cúspide de mi carrera allá arriba
mis padres dijeron nos vamos
y yo que yo soy de ankara
i
[Música]
[Risas]
pero no vamos entonces fuimos para atrás
y ahí entré como en una pequeña
depresión
no sabía dónde actuar y en ese momento
decidí armar un grupo en mi colegio para
estudiar para hacer
y nos presentamos hicimos un concurso en
el papel y luego mis viejos me dijeron
bueno estamos un poquito más arriba nos
vamos agua
y nos vemos en el campo y yo dios mío
en un momento cuando cumplí los 16 y
terminé el colegio
castilla
[Risas]
y yo tengo un sueño quiero ser feliz y
lo sé
y entonces tenía el sueño de ver a
estudiar argentina actuación muy bien
como me dijeron muy bien no estudiar
anna ahorra tu bolsa de viaje y yo te
voy a pagar el pasaje
y me vine arriba
y sea vendedora
y luego
y me dijeron no no
[Música]
gloria
llegué al estudio a la escuela de
actuación y una cuenta bancaria
busque las nombres de los que habían
ingresado
y no está mi nombre no estaba
entré en una depresión y una pequeña
depresión no sabía qué hacer con mi vida
ese era mi único sueño ir a estudiar
para hacer
y me habían rechazado pero como tenía
que mantenerme tenía que buscar
así que busquen trabajo nuevamente
financiera en call center en un
restaurante y dije no era eso así que
voy a estar en el trabajo y mi amiga me
dijo sí pero vos estás gorda
[Música]
y yo
[Risas]
en ese momento dije que a un
nutricionista en hermanos el perfil
nutricional medio una dieta empecé a
bajar de peso iba al gimnasio perfecto
y esta vez se empezó a volver un poco
excesiva para mí entonces en vez de
comer lo que me mandaban comía la mitad
porque tenía una
en un momento baje 30 kilos en dos meses
y en ese momento me di cuenta que estaba
con una anorexia
había caído en la anorexia y fue una de
los momentos más duros debilidad porque
perdí la regla
pelo uñas perdí mi luz perdí todo la
gente lloraba y decía por favor come y
yo nada más decía no lo voy a lograr
porque me lo dicen la sociedad tenemos
que ser regadas para triunfar cuando
decidí volver cuando llegue el perú
cuando llegas
sí
[Música]
[Risas]
y en verdad esperar
es mi sueño
y al escuchar que se podía montar así
exige a voy a avanzar una sola vez
prometo luego mantenerme en línea vomité
una vez
luego vomité dos veces luego se volvió
algo muy consecuente en mis siete veces
al día diez veces al día
estuve metida un día andy de un día sin
poder ir a ningún casting porque
simplemente me veía fea gorda y en el
punto que busque mi familia busqué a
todas esas personas dentro de mi familia
que me decían por ahora no vas a lograr
nada cosas así que son súper fuertes que
lo hacen de broma pero que te quieren
no sé cómo se sale esto y empecé a
buscar ayuda provendrá da por acá sería
por allá y de repente termine sola en el
hospital con los cambios inflamados
en la piel
por mi vida y en ese momento me acepte y
me acepte como era y dije tengo que ser
agradecida por el cuerpo que tengo esto
es un vehículo lo importante es lo que
está dentro del alma
eso es voy a hacer agradecida con
respecto y desde ese momento en que me
acepte comencé a ser feliz
en ese momento decidí hacer stand up
comedy decidí dejar de vomitar después
de casi un año y empecé a hacer stand up
comedy para burlarme de mí misma entré
al club de la comedia' luego hice un
casting en la radio y quedé en estudios
tuve un programa de radio luego de la
nada me pasa
un casting para un musical llamado
hairspray dirigido por juan carlos
fisher y dije entonces
[Música]
es la protagonista
[Risas]
me estaba riendo de mí esto es hacer
parte como somos aceptarse como
[Música]
me falta algo amigos el amor
y
y conocí
ah
[Música]
[Aplausos]
estos mismos nos volvimos enamorados
tenía todo tenía todo lo que había
pedido saqué el libro del amor con la
editorial planeta
pero por dentro no estaba tan contenta
me estaba quedando paralizada muchos no
saben pero desde los 13 años con una
lesión en la espalda
me dijeron que iban a tener que ponerme
42 una placa
y aprendí a caminar en un año porque si
no no iba a poder caminar en el futuro
iba a ser invadida
y a los 24 años cuando me encontraba
nuevamente con el amor ahí
en las piernas estaba entrando el tronco
y le preguntaba los universos que me
pasan lo que tengo que hacer para salir
de esto no puede hacer que tenga todo
este así una noche sueña con unas
mujeres que me dijeron que eran mis
francesas estas fueron sus palabras
somos sus ancestros y estaban todas
vestidas de negro se acaba y me dijeron
que estaban muy tristes porque no están
disfrutando de la vida y lo que tiene
que hacer es renunciar a todo y de
recorrer el mundo
cuando escuché estas mujeres es decir me
dicen me levanté y me di cuenta que
tenía razón estaba cuatro años en la
radio sentada en una silla hablando
trascendente que ya no me llena pero que
me quedaba con un suelo que me pagaban
ellos que iba a hacer con mi vida como
podía salir de ahí y me quedaba ahí y el
cuerpo habla estaba siendo infeliz
entonces en este momento levante a mí
y me dijo nada
y entonces él me eligió digestión
renoció y me dijo pero qué vas a hacer
el mundo me dijo lo mismo
bueno
ah
decidimos pasar más conmigo en un
homenaje a nuestro niño interior y nos
pasamos disfrazados de lo que queríamos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
i
y de repente nos fuimos de viaje si me
preguntan cuál que hemos ahorrado les
digo nunca va a ser suficiente
simplemente cuando tiras largas
de dónde están entonces nos vimos y nos
fuimos
por varios países este vino en méxico a
esta noruega después saludó después
román ya estamos a dedo viajamos a cabo
también en bus viajamos también de todas
formas fuimos mil oficios y fui
barrendera fui vendedora y yo
en este momento somos actrices de la
vida entonces mi papel soy vendedor debe
llegar a todos los papeles bien puestos
y de repente cuando estábamos viajando
mi marido me dice escuchado sobre una
planta que ayudar mucho al ser humano
este canal es y tienes que ir a buscarlo
porque tienes que dejar todas las
pastillas que estás tomando fuimos a
colombia encontramos en la serie de
canales y no podía creer que esas
plantas estuviera cambiando en mi vida
no sentí más dolor estaba alucinada en
ese momento tomaba aceite de cannabis y
dije pero necesito algo más para
complementar esto y fue que mi esposo me
dijo veamos terrícolas
ninguno de los dos éramos veganos vimos
este documental llamado terrícolas que
habla sobre cómo el ser humano ha
utilizado a los animales en comida en
los laboratorios en ropa en diversión
para todo y automáticamente cambiamos el
chip y nos volvimos veganos todo este
cambio que la sege más el organismo
hicieron que se me vaya todo todos los
dolores y comencé a ver la vida de otra
mano
estábamos recibir la llamada más triste
de mi vida y más a mi mamá no había
tenido un paro cardíaco
había trascendido teníamos que volver yo
les digo presente porque eres chica a mí
me han enseñado la que nosotros somos
energía y la energía jamás muere si no
se transforma decidimos regresar al perú
y fue cuando encontré una tarta de ella
dos días antes de que atrás
me decían que nuestra obligación de ser
feliz
es la única obligación en esta vida en
este plano que estaba en el camino
fue en ese momento que teníamos tanto
por comunicar que mi marido creó un
movimiento llamado donde
e increíbles y yo decidí hacer un
unipersonal llamado salto sin paracaídas
donde también compartía todo lo que
había venido y cuando experimente mi
personal estaba embarazada de una niña
que fue otro viaje yo estaba embarazada
de una niña metro terror por un momento
porque los doctores me dijeron tenido
poder ganar mi perdida que no lo voy a
poder hacer porque a partir del quinto
mes tenía que estar postrada en una cama
[Música]
de salir embarazada por la lesión que
tenía en la columna así que nos fuimos a
eeuu
investigamos sobre el cannabis y el
embarazo y encontré a doctores a madres
canastas a niños a adultos a personas
que habían consumido la plata mientras
estaban embarazadas y había sido el
embarazo más feliz que habían tenido
porque es una planta que ayuda mucho a
las mujeres fue una ósea con los duelos
para los náuseas tras los dolores para
todo consumir esta planta todo mi
embarazo cargué mi barbilla por nueve
meses sin sentir dolor sin sentir
náuseas sin sentir nada y luego di
gracias
de un punto de vida en que nació muy
bien y ella fue mi inspiración para
crear cuentos infantiles y ahora estoy
por sacar un libro que se llama corela y
sus amigos del mar
ahora soy cuentacuentos con mi tía sobre
donde contamos cuentos sobre el amor a
nosotros hasta la tierra y llevamos ese
mensaje a los niños que son el futuro de
nuestro país
con todo eso lo que quiero decirles es
que sigan sus sueños siempre es que el
hecho de ver estas mujeres en este sueño
que me eligieron corta con ese
sufrimiento y me dio a entender que
nosotros muchos repetimos patrones
con cosas que no son muestras sino que
son de nuestra mamá de nuestra abuela de
nuestra mis abuela entonces simplemente
hay que sacarnos todo eso porque está en
nuestra responsabilidad cortar por rizo
para poder ser felices y dejarnos un
camino limpio a nosotros y en nuestras
próximas generaciones porque es nuestra
obligación
[Aplausos]